suite de notre série sur les jeunes en
campagne après les jeunes partisans de
monsieur balladur c'était avant-hier
voici ceux qui soutiennent activement la
candidature de monsieur lionel jospin
reportage guilaine chenu didier da une
heure du matin c'est l'heure de sortie
lui de collage nuit blanche à bord de la
camionnette des affiches et une poignée
de militants ils ont entre 18 et 25 ans
ce sont les novices les sans grades de
la politique c'est la première
présidentielle et leurs premiers
frissons
il joue à se faire peur en collant sur
des territoires très convoités comme la
fac d'assas mjs dans la voulu toucher
les jeunes parce que depuis quelques
temps nous fait croire que chirac y
était mais est aimé par la jeunesse
je crois que c'est faux je crois qu'on
aime la marionnette des bêtes noires ils
en ont plusieurs
en une nuit il colle du jeu ce pas sûr
du balladur du chirac et du le clown
avec tous les moyens du bord mais là
pour alimenter sur le fond aussi un
discours pour faire des propositions
mais il faut voir le collage aussi d'
affiches comme un moment qu'il reçoit
aussi des militants qui à un moment de
convivialité et c'est aussi pour ça que
nous on aime coller leur autonomie les
jeunesses socialistes y tienne il était
gardien ils sont sans état d'âme aux
côtés de lionel josse pas occulter ils
ont droit à la parole n'est pas le
budget alors pour les tee-shirts et le
casque est il en famille se restreindre
dessus décrit violée devant l'autre
forme derrière nos points morts y
compris avec peu de moyens il leur faut
donner de la voix dans les victimes
qu'ils sont au premier rang pour
soutenir un candidat qu'ils découvrent
jeunes et sérieux en contrepartie de la
compétence des émotions et aussi des
plaisirs celui de voir lionel jospin
reprendre certaines de leurs
propositions sur le sida la drogue ou
l'égalité des chances
il a tenu à ce que de vrais jeunes non
pas quelques apparatchiks ou députés qui
ont 30 est en 32 ans auprès de lui de
vrais jeunes qui partagent les mêmes
conditions d'existence que ce soit qui
s'est adressé ce soir la campagne ils
ont le sentiment de la vivre aux
premières loges aussi demain la victoire
n'est pas au bout du chemin il se
prépare à devenir le politique de demain
[Musique]